salut le mental blog du jour sera
beaucoup plus veloppe que mentale parce
qu'aujourd'hui avec camions qui passent
parce qu'aujourd'hui pour la première
fois j'ai rendez-vous ou youtube space
et je vais essayer de vous emmener avec
moi je me suis à bien un endroit où ça
va pas choquer quelqu'un que j'ai une
caméra c'est au youtube space je vous
emmène du côté de saint lazare
le youtube space se trouve ovi rues de
londres donc c'est pas très loin de
saint lazare où je remonte la rue
d'amsterdam et j'y suis et donc la
formation à laquelle j'ai assisté parce
qu'ils font des formations et ça c'est
super c'est monter soi même monté tout
seul en fait j'espère que je vais
apprendre des astuces moi aussi à mon
tour c'est aussi pour monter un peu plus
efficacement ou où je sais pas en fait
ça devrait plus trop et trop loin je
pense
s'ils peuvent planter
je
je viens de finir la formation dans
youtube space malheureusement je n'ai
pas pu filmer en fait à partir d'un
endroit quand on rentre chez google on
peut plus filmer ça j'étais un peu
dégoûté de ça je vous avoue donc j'ai
pas pu faire d'image mais deux en plus
le lieu il est tellement ouf chercher il
doit y avoir des reportages des trucs
comme ça quand elles abattent un peu à
la silicon valley tout tu as envie de
diaby tes envies de travail c'est
incroyable c'est juste incroyable
du coup j'ai fait un autre formation qui
s'appelle unlock the space qui va me
permettre de pouvoir tourner aussi des
vidéos là-bas d'utiliser matériel et je
crois que je vais déménager en fait au
youtube space je cherche la lumière
marchand parce que j'ai eu deux heures
aussi formation sur la lumière et en
fait ça c'est le truc un peu déprimant
tu sors de cette formation tu dis ah
ouais à ya encore du chemin en fait pour
avoir des vidéos de qualité mais tant
mieux c'est à dire que durant les
semaines qui viennent je vais peut-être
réussir à sortir des vidéos de plus
grande qualité après la difficulté c'est
de prendre en compte le fait d'en faire
une par jour
mais il va falloir surtout des petites
économies avant de pouvoir faire le
petit investissement peut lasser là
c'est la première vidéo où il n'y a pas
vraiment de trucs de mentalisme mais je
trouvais ça cool de vous emmener un
petit peu dans mon périple de la journée
de ma découverte de youtube en fait je
suis passé de mon rapport à youtube qui
suis alors dit sur le terrain en réel
je repars donc j'ai juste un truc à vous
dire pensez à vous abonner à la chaîne
évidemment parce que c'est grâce à vous
que je suis motivé aussi à faire tout ça
et à faire toutes ces formations pour
vous faire des vidéos de meilleure
qualité
à demain 11h ciao